beerdigung in corona zeiten eine kleine
trauergemeinde alle auf abstand keine
umarmung kein trost nur die letzte
erinnerung ein paar bestürzt am heiligen
abend nachts und hat sich dann ein
schenkel gebrochen kam ins krankenhaus
nachts und dort haben sie den getestet
natürlich und er war positiv
und dann kam auf die station und ab da
was als sehr schwierig alfred raths
stirbt elf tage später ohne dass seine
familie ihn noch einmal sehen oder auch
nur sprechen kann
er ist 64 jahre verheiratet vater und
großvater ein familienmensch am ende
ganz allein in einem klinik zimmer in
pforzheim
ich habe versucht mir deine schwächen zu
sprechen arzt zu reden aber sie ist ja
immer ja feiertag wenn jemand da der
meldet sich jemand bei ihnen mal ganz
schwierig lacht okay bitte anrufen
action tag immer angerufen und dann kam
plötzlich einen anruf von meinem bruder
des krankenhauses an kubas gestorben
ich finde schön schuldig würde auch für
die familie des machen weil ich den
kontakt halten müssen
ich hab's geschafft und ich sehen immer
alleine dem zimmer lieber allein
ich habe das vertrauen gehabt und ich
war auch noch viel zu verständnisvoll
dann findest du nicht meine anrufe waren
zur übergabe alles gleich nochmal an
kein arzt sind da kein problem ich rufe
noch mal an und ich glaube das war das
problem
ich hatte viel energischer auftreten es
aber es ist jetzt zu spät den eigenen
tod stirbt man nur einmal den seiner
liebsten immer wieder schuld versagen
machtlosigkeit gefühle die in corona
zeiten mehr gewicht bekommen
es gibt eine menge menschen die solche
schuldgefühle haben und ich versuche sie
ja sie sozusagen ein bisschen davon frei
zu machen da sie zu ermutigen
doch noch mal zu gucken also eher auf
das zu gucken was zu lebzeiten war also
auf die beziehung zu schauen die sie
geführt haben also dieses gewicht auf
dieses allerletzte nur zulegen aber
schwierig
[Musik]
sara benz sieht immer das licht auch in
dunklen zeiten schon deswegen tut es gut
mit ihr über den tod zu sprechen
selbstbestimmt sterben und trauern
darauf setzt sie als bestatterin und
trauerbegleiterin dass sich das sterben
durch corona entscheidend verändert hat
bereitet allerdings auch ihr sorgen vor
allen dingen ist es und vieles einsamer
geworden
also das ist glaube ich das was die
menschen am meisten belastet sowohl die
die sterben als auch die zugehörigen
dass ihr nicht zueinander können dass es
keinen physischen kontakt gibt dass die
besuchs regeln so streng sind
das ist glaube ich das was das sterben
vor allen dingen erschwert sara benz hat
einen videoblog über tod und trauer
produziert dafür filme sack geschichten
und sie versucht brücken zu bauen
also wenn ich die nachricht bekomme
jemand ist gestorben dann ist das erst
mal was ich nur im kopf habe und die
leitung vom kopf zum herzen die ist
länger als nur der abstand von meinen
händen
also es kann sehr hilfreich und
wohltuend sein dass wirklich zu spüren
ja zu begreifen
begreifen setze eben auch nähe voraus
nähe die die regeln in der pandemie
verbieten
[Musik]
das musste auch ralf brepohl aus berlin
erfahren als das virus ihm seine mutter
nahm ich habe mich vier wochen aus einem
raus gezogen ich war krank geschrieben
und habe dann vier wochen einfach so mit
meiner trauer und meinen gedanken
hingegeben habe über meine mama
nachgedacht oder einfach über die
endlichkeit des lebens an sich
ich war nicht dabei wahrscheinlich war
das ein dunkles kein zimmer wo sonst
niemand war und dann ist das leben
plötzlich zu ende also möchte man nicht
so möchte man nicht die welt verändern
[Musik]
ich habe immer überlegt wie sie hat sie
das gekriegt weil sie ist ja nicht aus
dem heim raus sie saß im rollstuhl oder
lag im bett und war immer auf dieser
etage
ich habe gedacht wenn ich das jetzt
gewesen bin also diese gedanken kann mir
wenn ich jetzt dieses videos
weitergegeben hatte
ich bin auch immer man daran trotzdem
maske habt die hand vor den mund
gehalten und dann habe ich mit ihr
geredet irgendwie so gut es ging
ich will niemals verzeihen
[Musik]
ralf brepohl hatte nico röhner symptome
wurde aber auch nie getestet
es ist der gedanke an die mögliche
schuld die ihn bis heute verfolgt und
der gedanke an ihren einsamen und
anonymen tod eine zahl in der pandemie
statistik seine mutter ist am 31 oktober
verstorben und ich hab dann die zahlen
gehört am ersten november und ich weiß
die zahl nicht mehr ich weiß das sind
noch eine eins drin war ja irgendwie und
ich dachte okay die einst das ist ein
hammer habe ich ihn sofort in dem moment
gedacht
das krankenhaus in dem sie starb durfte
er nicht betreten konnte ihr nicht
beistehen
abschied nehmen war erst am grab möglich
ich habe das dann für mich so gemacht
dass ich einen brief geschrieben habe
und ich habe diesen brief in ihr grab
mit rein getan
das war für mich so ein ritual um mich
zu verziehen
nun besucht er ihr grab regelmäßig
es ist ja noch nicht alles verarbeitet
diese trauer na das ist ja alles ganz
neu für mich und ich sitz hier förmlich
hinein mal die woche wenn du zehn
minuten sind und so ich finde friedhof
hier wunderschön zum zweiten ich wohne
hier in der nähe oft dort einkaufen in
der markthalle und dachte mir das ist
der richtige ort dann kann ich mal nicht
vorbeiwinken
[Musik]
auch mit ihrem tod hat niemand gerechnet
sie hatte keine chronischen krankheiten
die trauerfeier im engsten familienkreis
und doch für jeden mit einem klick zu
erreichen so hätte sie es wohl gewollt
britannia kam die junge influenza in aus
hamburg lebte in und für die sozialen
netzwerke
an ihre fans und follower richtete sie
noch voller hoffnung ihre letzten
öffentlichen worte wer mit mir ist kennt
keine trauer
wer mich kennt kann nur lachen und seine
sorgen wenigstens für kurze zeit
vergessen
ich werde das durchstehen mit gottes
hilfe
knapp zwei wochen später stirbt
britannia
sie ist erst 29 jahre alt mitten aus dem
leben gerissen
nennt es ihr verlobter mahnung
gemeinsame pläne hatten sie hochzeit
wollten sie feiern ein ganzes leben vor
sich
letztendlich als dann die nachricht kam
dass sie es nicht geschafft hat durfte
ich noch mal zu ihr nicht bei ihr
verabschieden
und ja das ist wirklich unvorstellbar zu
sehen dass deine frau da liegt ohne ohne
energie im körper das unvorstellbare auf
jeden fall das wünsche ich niemandem
ihre hand noch einmal im krankenhaus
halten als sie noch lebte
das hätte sich manu gewünscht sie
begleiten nun sind es seine freunde und
der glaube was ihm kraft in seiner
trauer gibt auf jeden fall beten
leider nicht zusammen aber jede freie
minute die wir finden auf jeden fall
dass wir für sie beten für uns beten
allgemein dass wir gesund bleiben aber
in gedanken ist sie heute immer noch bei
uns und das macht diesen verlust ein
bisschen einfacher so uns auf jeden fall
auch auf der kuhwiese intensivstation
des klinikums stuttgart werden die
patientinnen und patienten immer jünger
wir waren schon öfter hier immer waren
die meisten über 80 nun aber viele um 65
und sie liegen oft wochenlang
jeder ist pflege leiterin der station
eine mit viel herz die menschen die sie
pflegt können das aber nur spüren soll
ich hab mir ein patient gesagt sie
machen so viel für mich
wissen sie wenn ich das überlebe und sie
auf der straße mal sehen würde
ich würde sie nicht erkennen das
belastet mich auch sehr ich würde sie
nicht erkennen ich könnte mich nicht
aber in gedanken ich habe kein gesicht
zu ihnen
und jetzt stellen sich die lage des
patienten vor der muss ihn vertrauen
obwohl er überhaupt gar kein gesicht
dazu hat oft aber weiß auch nichts über
ihre patientinnen und patienten weil sie
im koma liegen und die angehörigen sie
nicht besuchen dürfen
elisabeth ist seit mitte dezember hier
nach wochenlangen koma kämpft sie sich
jetzt zurück ins leben
schon große bedeutung wie versuchen sie
den jetzt ein bisschen sich in anfang an
war und die für mich da ist das halt
niemand herkommen kann sonst während die
jeden job da das belastet sie oder haben
sie schon mal mit ihrer familie
kommunizieren können wir ja schon
telefoniert das kann ich
sehr sehr schön und ich möchte bald
wieder zu den es sind menschen wie
elisabeth die hoffnung geben dass jetzt
sei die größte herausforderung ihres
berufslebens sagt sie die 49-jährige ist
marathon läuferin gewohnt lange
durchzuhalten ihr blick aufs leben aber
hat sich verändert
nun wird er nachdenklich und denkt halt
auch dass das ganze ist sehr fragil der
mensch ist sehr fragil und man tut alles
und trotzdem verliert man dann kommt das
ist jetzt so und der tod gehört zum
leben dazu und das machen einfach weiter
an den lebenden
die kaufen uns hier auch mal man kann
nicht mit jedem toten sterben 18
intensivbetten hat die cubis station in
stuttgart während wir bei ihrer arbeit
begleiten stirbt in wird vier eine
63-jährige hat sie tage zuvor
aufgenommen noch hoffnungsfroh dass wir
uns zu besiegen angehörigen betreuer
michael kloss hat die familie angerufen
einmal dürfen sie kommen zum abschied
nehmen
ein einsamer tod
wir wissen nicht was die patienten
wahrnehmen um sich herum
wir wissen dass nicht sie bekommen
medikamente dass sie sich den stress
geraten dass sie keine schmerzen haben
keine art mode gekommen und wir sagen
die wahrnehmung wird ausgeschaltet
drumherum wir wissen aber nicht was sie
wirklich wahrnehmen ob es etwas die
übergeordnet es gibt von dem was wir
wissen und deswegen weiß ich nicht ob er
es einfacher ist stefan kohl hat coop 19
knapp überlebt jetzt kämpfte in der
therapie mit jedem atemzug nach 108
tagen auf der intensivstation der
münchen klinik schwabing ist seine lunge
massiv geschädigt weil es einfach
eingeschränkt ja wenn man eine treppe
läuft dann hat man ein riesenproblem
hinterher und ich habe einfach so das
bedürfnis mehr luft zu atmen ja und als
ich eigentlich rein kriege in meinem
einem blutkreislauf und da sind die
schnittstellen einfach durch den virus
ganz schön beschäftigt neulich wurde
noch ein cd gemacht und da hat der
radiologe gesagt also dass ihre lunge
schaut nicht gut aus das sind richtige
fehlstellen ja oder löcher also ich
glaub ich ausgedrückt und ja ich sollte
mir mal gedanken machen über eine
transplantation bis heute verfolgen wohl
seine koma träume die tote mutter aber
auch fremde menschen erschienen ihm in
der welt zwischen leben und tod
ich habe mich das selbst obwohl kein
fernseher darauf einer weißen band habe
ich dann gesehen was sie mit mir gemacht
habe aber so zehn minuten zeitversetzt
ja und ich hab mir dann im traum gedacht
wenn du das jetzt sie ist dann bist ja
nicht tot
du siehst ja noch was die mit dir machen
seit der krankheit ist das leben des 64
jährigen nicht mehr wie es war
lunge niere herz haben massiv gelitten
er lag über zwei monate im künstlichen
koma dreimal musste er not intubiert
werden
also ich dann wieder aufgewacht bin aus
dem koma kaum ärzte und pflegerinnen und
pfleger von überall her und haben sich
gefreut dass ich wieder da bin und so
ich fühle mich hier in diesem mit diesem
land eigentlich sehr verbunden weil die
wirklich um die menschen kümmern die
hier wohnen ja und kann ich nur sagen
toll also in england oder in amerika
wäre ich es wahrscheinlich wirklich tot
oder pleite menschen die wie stefan kohl
das virus überlebt haben sind für das
personal im krankenhaus ein
hoffnungsschimmer bei all den sterben
zusehen dass ich ihre arbeit lohnt auch
für sie ist noch dynamik drin ja
nach 76 tagen im koma hatte stefan buhl
angst vor dem tod
ich habe auch gedacht ich hab noch zu
tun ja ich habe noch viele träume ich
will noch weiter leben ich habe nicht
gedacht dass ich jetzt abstellen und ich
mag mich mehr oder so ich wollte meine
kinder noch aufwachsen sehen und andere
träume stefan kohl hat es geschafft fast
60.000 andere menschen in deutschland
nicht so viele abschiede in zeiten von
distanz was können angehörige tun wenn
sie nicht zum verstorbenen gehen dürfen
auch dazu hat sara benz ein video
produziert mit einer freundin szenen
nachgestellt
ich würde allen mut machen die
pflegenden zu bitten ein foto zu machen
oder eine haarsträhne abzuschneiden oder
einen handabdruck zu machen kann man ihm
stempelkissen auf dem blatt papier
machen das ist jetzt auch nicht was was
ganz viel zeit braucht
[Musik]
dass sie irgendetwas haben zum angucken
zum anfassen zum spüren dass da jemand
gestorben ist
[Musik]
zeit sei es jetzt für einen offeneren
umgang mit dem thema findet sara benz
[Musik]
was ich mir sehr wünschen würde ist dass
wir neben diesem ganzen schrecklichen
was diese pandemie uns gebracht hat
vielleicht auch ein paar chancen
erkennen zum beispiel die chance danach
zu fragen wie wollen wir eigentlich
unsere abschiede gestalten was ist denn
da wichtig wollen wir vielleicht doch
ein bisschen mehr die toten zu uns holen
weil wir jetzt merken das ist doch
wichtig ist sich mit allen sinnen zu
verabschieden also so eine diskussion
das wünsche ich mir sehr
die pandemie als chance über das ende
und den schmerz zu reden
corona hat das sterben verändert und
spuren werden bleiben
[Musik]